finally i'm sorry that i have to tell
you about this but i do it's my
obligation a social media influencer
named stephanie mato has been raising
tens of thousands of dollars selling her
farts in a jar this is a real thing
and if you're wondering about the ins
and outs of this business here she is
explaining it
hey guys today i'm going to be showing
you a day in the life of a girl who
sells her farts in a jar so i like to
get things rolling with some beans a
protein muffin sometimes even a yogurt
less sugar is better
some hard-boiled eggs and today i
decided i was going to make myself a
protein shake with some yogurt added to
it and oh i was feeling it for sure
while i wait for those parts to develop
i like to read i'm very smart love to
read and then after i'm ready to go i go
ahead and you know do my work do my job
i don't need to show you that guys but i
like to add in little flower petals i
feel like they attach the scent and make
it last longer and when i'm finally
finished with my jar i like to leave a
personalized note i want to thank you so
much the 97 people who have already
purchased their jar of farts and as you
know they're on sale right now 50 off of
1 000
so grab my unfiltered and check it
well you know that's one way to earn
some gas money
i guess a guy who buys uh one of the
jars is a man after her own fart
but look i mean she did build this
business from the ground up and that's
good because uh sometimes you just have
to fart from scratch
sorry i'm done maybe anyway tragedy has
struck and uh this is the latest update
about stephanie she apparently she's now
out of the farts selling game this is
from metro news that says a former 90
day fiance star has um made a staggering
38 thousand dollars a week from selling
her farts in a jar
but now she's revealed that she was
rushed to the hospital stephanie mato
recently shed light on her unusual
stream of income explaining how she
utilized her 260 000 strong following as
her customer base to sell her pungent
product
but now she says that after a medical
incident she has to get out of the
business entirely
it says she may have squeezed out one
too many as the reality star had to make
a hospital dash she told jam press quote
i thought i was having a stroke and that
these were my final moments i was
overdoing it
she recalled how she consumed three
protein shakes and a huge bowl of black
bean soup in one day before feeling that
something quote was not right with a
pressure in her stomach that moved up
through her body she thought she was
having a heart attack and now her
doctors have advised her to stop doing
this so that's the end of her business
but you know maybe she'll start it back
up at a later date
and that'll be good maybe because you
know what they say
absence makes the fart grow fonder
i said i was done i had to do one more
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated